[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 27 of
GameSpot after dark this is GameSpot's
official video game podcast my name is
Jake I'm your host and I'm joined this
week by Lucy James ie losing your accent
oh no why I am going to make a concerted
effort to be peak British in this I'm
just saying it before the comments say
it because so far every episode someone
in the comments has been very sad about
your your accent that's just fading away
they've never even heard my real accent
this British one like received
pronunciation is fake I'm from the north
of England I've got a very strong
Geordie accent when I'm drunk or what
I'm talking to my mother
well it is true we got a lot of beers
over there hiding behind their tan
you're the beer collector one to the
podcast I just want to say your hair is
looking fantastic
I said we weren't gonna talk about this
I know and that's why I'm talking about
it don't tell me what I can't cause it's
great it's one of those barber shops
that has whisky for free right oh really
yeah whisky nothing what what did you
say for your hair I said how does if
someone is watching this video how do
they get there Jake I said I want I
wanna I want a two on the sides with the
fader up and a trim up top there you go
every what does that mean yeah that I
have to show a picture to the lady
this is tweet us and show us your Jake
haircuts where they look like Jake so no
haircuts on our coat Jake's
I hope the cameras it's me if it's not
this is gonna look very weird in that
camera
also joining us this week is Callie I'm
stealing Lucy's Xiao Mei hello
wait now hang on those three British
people and this and this I'm not British
I do it British yeah thank you
well I I blame the BBC Pride and
Prejudice six hours of Pride and
Prejudice : the Colin Firth Oh God I
love it so much when I talk to my mom I
I get progressively more Valley though
mmm yeah you do that you do Maya what
well yeah when I can't hear tomorrow
you're the only prime not trying to be
it's not like I'm like I'm one of those
people that's like I just want to be
British like I just I talk to you guys a
lot and I like you so this thing like I
live in America now I live with an
American and a Canadian she's more
French then I think Greg obviously but
like I just I'm like rolek for accents
everything I touch I just I'm
desperately holding on to my London
accident well my East London accident
could be way way WAY worse roadman
that's my standard a way of speaking but
I won't do it I've but I have to speak
like this like it's not an accent but
it's like a different kind of way of
speaking that most people can make sense
of otherwise I'd just be like dizzy
Roscoe some nonsense like that we had a
video meeting one time it was like I
think when Chris first moved to the
United States and he was going off about
how we say water it was like water its
water he started saying war war water he
said mobile data instead of betta Randy
will switch mmm like he'll say mobile
the first time and then he'll say mobile
the next time Randy's from Australia I
know but other people whose ready
sorry Randy's our other chief yeah my
went off on me once in a fun way because
I was staying with her and I said oh you
don't have to pick me up from the train
station I'll get a cab and she was like
okay you have that word I mean well she
lives she also lives in like near Wales
and they don't even have over there some
bit Wales the bus says boss on the side
like BW s that was pretty cool then I
went to a museum or something in Wales
and they had Welsh Scrabble and it was
really intimidating Welsh Scrabble front
of the show me the most Welsh man alive
Wow we've got on such a tangent already
but we have another Welshman on staff we
have got Dave Falls yeah that's true but
I mean they both have beards gaff is
Gabbie so Welsh that we have a what's up
group that sounds like it's such a sub
for Jersey
[Laughter]
we on this what's up group and we were
talking about bite cuz Rory's always on
bite and getting again he's got some
really good bites inland it's very good
Rory has powers Murray has powers
following Mumbai uh big fan Gavin
look at him gets a few rebates thinks
he's Tom Jones is like Gavin is like
look I was panicking the only famous
person I could think of was Tom Jones I
think it's the most Welsh thing I've
ever heard of well you know it's not
unusual
anyway before we go to what we've been
playing we have a special segment the
Chris from Dayton Ohio or Kevin's Chris
from Dayton Ohio 2.0 segment it's been
upgraded it's been upgraded normally we
save the Chris from Dayton Ohio segment
when we've got a new guest on however we
figured we'd run through this updated
version with everyone sitting here today
basically wait do we need a new jingle
this has to be like the read there it is
we got it anyway he sent us a bunch of
questions that we have to answer as
quickly as possible and I figure if I
remember will save this from we have
guests on - how we gonna do because it's
like four of us like a million questions
so are you gonna give us a one question
each or is everyone gonna answer it's
rapid fire so I think Jake should read
answer then tame answer than me answer
okay okay we'll start right here and
mmo's DPS healer or tank DPS tank healer
heal in Pokemon grass fire or water
starter fire war water fire sonic or
Mario Mario Mario Sonic
Mario life is stranger Walking Dead
night strange Walking Dead welcome Dead
Season one life estranged season one yes
both I know I guess I said neither so
what I think if we can't answer we're
supposed to say sorry Chris yes sorry
Chris sorry Kevin sorry Kevin and Chris
yeah yep
gone home are what remains of Edith
Finch what remains of you - Finch gone
home gone home Finch
mortal kombat or street fighter mortal
kombat street fire mortal kombat street
huh huh halo overwatch seed your Call of
Duty halo probably mouston keyboard or
controller preferred controller for
first person shooters mouse and keyboard
for everything else controller
controller controller but specifically
the Xbox elite - yep
prepared on-rails games are open world
open world open world open world open
worlds but I assume they mean on Rails
is in like more linear yeah in my mind
I'm thinking of you know we could do a
2.1 with some clarifications question
yeah Kevin can listen to this maybe get
back to us with update Chris from Dayton
Ohio 2.1 FPS games shotgun assault rifle
or sniper sniper sniper assault rifle
assault rifle co-op single player
multiplayer single player single-player
single-player xbox playstation nintendo
pc or my favorite ooh yeah yeah tangent
sponsored the year game Expo in
2011-2012 and if you went you got one
different okay if you were near the
center you go so much as looked at
through the windows of the convention
hall they'd give you one my brother came
back from the I've got three years I
don't know it's three people and I was
like put them all in gave you free
batteries so you could use those
batteries in your Xbox 360 ok intento
probably for me though PlayStation
Nintendo PlayStation go ripping a bubble
pop-tarts our toaster strudel pop-tarts
toaster strudel pop-tarts specifically
s'mores yeah the good pop-tarts uh is it
cheating if a friend tells you how to
beat a part you're stuck on no no no no
is it cheating if you save scum
yes no no no Danny Oh dryer or a Dan
Reicher
I plead the fifth Danny I like Dan
Reicher a lot but too much history with
Danny yeah Danny yeah
games on a couch sure at a desk desk
couch here so like desk well I like bed
or desk I need to be fully sitting up or
lying down completely going back to the
mouse and keyboard if I'm playing a
first-person shooter
RTS idly deskah can you bear me please
so bad I play thank you I play games in
my bed so anything that's not that I'm
in that life as well and it's not
pleasant no I was considering getting
one of those like chair things from
Target where it's basically the backward
[Laughter]
favorite gaming snack Bombay mix oh say
takis Fuego cheese and crackers these
Starbucks cheese plate we get but I'm
trying not to buy it anymore I'm trying
to not get I'm trying to cook more I
bought an instant pot really proud when
you said you weren't getting there yeah
it has everything
it's thought sharp cheddar it's got brie
you got Apple Gouda yeah very good West
one official in there like the Dutch Oh
last one Miyazaki Sakurai Miyamoto our
Kojima Mizuki my mind Miyazaki Miyamoto
Miyazaki
damn some lady playing dude blood bone
again in a minute so oh what a game that
is do you like that game game that's
I don't can I can I just go can I just
throw in Kodaka the Duncan trump and
creator good night
alright dangit Rampal or danger grandpa
anyway that was the Chris from Dayton
Ohio segment 2.0 we'll bring that back
however Kevin might need to send us some
patch notes on that and clarify some
things any questions you think like
would be more fun any questions you
thought like oh there was one about
favorite controller did you skip
preferred controller oh we talked about
PC or controller right what's your
favorite the whole time oh I kind of
jumped the gun cuz I said like who's
that yeah oh I did skip that one
favorite controller Xbox elite
controller - I guess as well mad cat
statistic but I also really like the pro
controller on switch oh yeah PSU
controller is fantastic GameCube
controllers 10 to 64 controller would
say shouts out anyway that was my mouth
again I keep missing my mouth that was
Kevin's Chris from Dayton Ohio 2.0
segment but now we're moving on to what
we've been playing uh how should we
start this start cuz mine's nothing I've
just been playing Pokemon that's it
what are you doing it now are you still
coming I'm I'm so I've been left to do
so the new season of the like ranked
battles online ranked battles started so
I had been loitering on that using sage
and Parks Championship Invitational team
and I definitely am struggling against
Charizard and torkoal teams so I bred a
melodic to use as a counter to that so
I'm trying to build a team around that
because I was getting so mad at the at
the Charizard teams they're really hard
to counter so you're you're really mad
at Oracle for a while
torkoal well sucks I hate her all so
much so he said talk well and I was like
mmhmm oh let's see my mum it's my mom's
friend your mom has a friend called talk
was a friend good more just exquisite
names
sounds like the cost of like a muppet
show yes that's I've just been I'm
trying to figure out right now I'm
getting I'm trying to get an Arcanine so
I have a whimsicott and I really like
Doral Adan which is onstage in parks
championship team it's a steal and
dragon-type pokémon and it's it's a
really good boy
so I've just been working on that those
good I mean I haven't really been
playing much either recently I played
more modern warfare and that's about it
I watched the outsider but no one has
that on Episode five was a bit oh he's
your bad it's not it's on this bad it's
just very slow and like not that much
happens weekly outside a segment blue
key part though it was so spooky that
was a spooky part no at the end when
they're like in the coming episodes it
looked no but I feel like this was I
watched four episodes lost well on
Saturday just a kid like yeah I'm gonna
try it was like 9:30 I was like I'll
watch one and get a favor of in see how
I feel no four episodes straight you
know in a row and I was so glad that my
roommate wasn't there cuz I was like a
vegging out like like she would care she
wouldn't care but like I feel bad like I
don't want to be like the weird dude
stuck in front of a TV for over four
hours in a row in a place cuz I'm using
her to watch it yeah she promised you
but yeah it's very very very good
episode four was like but also is like
interesting is more interesting than
like thrilling yeah man that's the other
the other episodes are like thrilling
that one's like because I think it's
kind of like I hope you talked to some
people of color before writing this up
those the one awkward thing where it was
like the mystical yes serious latina is
gonna tell you about a monster and I was
like but then I rewound it off of that
it's good show
great show fantastic show time you've
actually seen something new oh yeah so
I've seen and played something new blood
yeah would you want to see your play
wait see Wow I mean just to see what the
new thing you've played is given what
you've written on the run sheet u5s oh I
misread that as PlayStation 5 yeah yeah
toilet i walked up and towards like look
at this there was a new PS 5 in there
yeah persona 5 scramble the demo fur is
out now on the Japanese a shop very easy
to get on the Japanese eShop all you
really need to know is when you go to
the eShop you press the persona 5 tile
it's not the big button is the button
underneath it most people press the big
button it's like pay us so that's pretty
much it it's really easy to get it and
it's very much a persona it feels very
much like a persona game the gameplay
part of it is it's a missile game which
means dynasty warrior style action but
how many enemies can you fight at once
many a lot but I played for like an hour
I think but I only got like two small
sections of gameplay because like
persona 5 and every other persona game
very dense in terms of like setup and
storytelling and like I started off by
listening to what was going on and I was
like if I carry on like this I might not
never get I might never get to play the
game before the actual podcast but it
feels very much like a continuation of
the persona 5 game story they love atlas
loves doing canonical spin-offs they do
that with like their dancing games and
that kind of stuff so this is very much
in the
spirit of this is a follow-on from
persona 5 it takes place right after
persona 5 right well there's been a gap
in time it's like so like like based on
my understanding of Japanese which is an
advanced but enough to get by is like
his joke has been away for a while and
returns to like the the D to see all the
friends and family stuff that he's been
missing so the moment you go back to the
cafe and you meet soldier again I was
like oh man like I was overwhelmed like
I miss this because they use the same
music a lot like use the same soundtrack
they use the same a lot of the same
soundtrack because the rhythm of the
game so far feels very similar to
persona 5 like you start off in the cafe
and then more kana literally says let's
go to bed you go to sleep and you wake
up and I also still explore the city -
oh you can yeah so you can do that stuff
as well and there's a so based on the
story what's happened is there's some
sort of investigation team not the
investigation team from sono for an
investigation team that are like still
got their eyes on Joker and the Phantom
thieves and then like that's the thread
that it starts with and then it cuts to
Joker almost coming home and everyone
kind of like he got comes home to the
cafe and like the lights are off it
looks like it hasn't been touched in
ages doesn't look like anyone's there
like as you walk in the door opens you
can see like dust particles falling it
looks amazing and then like the lights
come on and they all they're like
surprising him to come back and then
like it's so cute it's just like the
small gang and soldier oh and it's so
like cute and like warm like like a warm
welcome home and then they go up and
they're planning like a they haven't
they're all talking about how they
haven't seen each other in ages and if
you've played that game and invested
like a hundred ish hours on it you will
feel like oh man this you will feel like
overwhelmed emotionally because even I
was like just seeing soldier oh and he
says something like oh man is so good to
have you back and then and then like
later on he says like troubles come back
into my life in a kind of like nice like
melancholic like like you know teenage
visiting again and you know he's up to
no good and about to cause a ruckus but
like did anyone say he Sasha booty
no one said it specially sadly so just
to clarify from while you play does it
seem like it's structured very similar
to persona 5 except instead of maybe the
dungeon crawling stuff it is then so so
it has dungeons it does have dungeons
you get pulled into what looked to be
like the met verse so like all of the
pillars of a persona game are there you
immediately go to the Velvet Room when
Morgan tells you to go sleep you wake up
in the velvet room
Igor is not there which if you played
personify will make sense to you for
various reasons but there is like you
talk about being the trickster and that
kind of stuff and then you wake up and
eventually there's an there's this whole
thing is about it seems like the main
first arc of the story of the face pipe
with first Palace is about a pop star I
forgot her name I think it's a DC which
is Alex or something like that but it's
it's an English name that has a Japanese
look Sonia she's from Alice in
Wonderland yeah yeah yeah so like it's
about her and she's like beloved pop
star and then you go to see her cuz a
few the I think it's I can't remember
who is but like one of the one the guys
is there and you get pulled into like a
Metaverse version of that area and she's
it's her palace basically and you can do
a dungeon and that's where I stopped
playing okay but it is very much that
same kind of style the Missal stuff is
very very well done from where I played
like super simple unlike
take take my excitement levels down a
notch because persona like just seeing
anything personally it raises it to a
bit like unreasonable levels anyway so
maybe like once I play more of it I
played like a few minutes of it here and
there maybe if I play more of it I'll
feel different but it just felt good
like the missile stuff where it's just
like running around and like you're
almost the enemies that you're facing
off against our security so they've got
them they've got like masks on them but
they they look like security and I think
they're supposed to be Alice's like
security team so you're like hacking and
slashing your way through them but like
it works in the strategic elements of
persona 5 and the RPG stuff really well
like you hold r1 and everything slows
and almost freezes actually and then
you've got basically this AoE kind of
like indicator and you can like move
that around and you select spells and
magic off that so if you've got like a
massive clump of enemies you can select
a fire spell and I'll tell you the day
week to this and then you hit them and
they'll all fall over and then it will
you can press a or I think it's X to do
like a all-out attack on em can you like
swap out what persona you have from what
you planned but like you could do that
tactical stuff you've got a other
characters when they're running around
with you they will sometimes knock over
an enemy and if you press a Joker will
do that jump towards them and execute
them and like you can hop from enemy to
enemy and so you can do like massive
stun attacks and drop them and then like
move around the battlefield it's got
really interesting traversal at one
point like you look remember at the
start of persona 5 where you had that
moment where you're hiding and it yeah
you did tutorial way it's like moving
from point to point and it does that
quick like a blur of a movement yeah
it's got something like that but you can
like look up into the end it's like a
lamppost we were fighting in like almost
like a should be your area where it's
massively populated I saw a lamppost
there and I pressed it and like you know
how noctus does his throw on his soil
and you press the button and he appears
there and he's like hanging on you do
that as Joker on to like a the top of a
lamppost and then you can like move
around lampposts like that around the
environment and you can press like X and
like swing down and start a spinning
kick like Sora does in Kingdom Hearts 3
like a spinning yes all spinning like
move and moving between points like
massive enemies it seems like a way more
dynamic way to move around the
environment
I had skull with me and they were he was
fighting and doing various other he's
his code name is cool isn't it
and doing like he was also fighting
alongside me in that dungeon but it just
felt really good and it felt like a
comfortable familiar experience they've
remixed some tracks which was there's a
version of last surprise which is fan
it's like a but rock version of it and
it's amazing I was listening to it for
like 20 30 minutes like I just had it
was on like a tutorial and pop-up I was
like I'm not gonna press X I'm just
gonna listen to this and I just listened
to it for ages bias also got like new
animated sequences to kind of thread the
story together it's got an intro he
feels very very very faithful to persona
5 so like I was definitely gonna play
and was was interested in it now I'm
like mega hype for it yeah I I wasn't
interested really in an ox or like
missile games as much as I liked persona
5 and I figured it would just be all
about the combat and maybe a little bit
of story but after hearing you talk
about it it sounds like it sounds like
it's more of that persona 5 storytelling
with some combat and stuff on the side
and it sounds like combats pretty good
too which is like not that I didn't
think it was gonna be good but for some
reason those kind of games I just have
so much trouble yeah like they just get
tiring after a while but if this if they
pull it off I feel like I could see
myself finishing that game yeah about
like what percentage of the dialogue and
storage were you able to pick up with
your Japanese probably like 60 50 to 60
percent like the problem was I started
off paying attention and I was like
picking a lot of it up but then I
realized it was gonna keep on going for
a race instead so at that point I was
just looking at specific words as they
appeared just to get enough
yep hit and trickster you know but like
it's really really cool like I they he
kind of had started you get all the team
into his room and everyone standing
there like Michael I was there and you
know everyone else is Morgan is there
and they're all kind of hanging out and
you're like I remember this this is like
it's like reuniting with friends there
genuinely felt that way and I was like
come into this already like this I'm
excited too because I feel like there
wasn't enough of the whole entire crew
together in that game because you didn't
really get everyone together into the
last dungeon or a second or last dungeon
I think so it'll be nice to in theory I
guess playing the entire game where it
is all of the phantom thieves together
in a room planning what they're gonna do
yeah not oh yeah in for like there's
such good characters and then you never
get in gear but they they seem to be
like connected what are porting over way
early and there's like some sort of can
see happening with you know they had
their phone in five they've now got
basically Siri like an AI Futaba is no
so the it's I think it's just like a
generic AI like Siri for on all phones
but it will play in but Futaba obviously
is the one who like tells Joker about
you because like a start speaking and
they're organizing a camping trip
through the the AI companion thing so I
think it's gonna have some sort of like
big element or presence in the story but
we'll see we'll see how that figures out
cool and there's no release date for the
United States right no state now it's
coming up soon in Japan benign the
states what about the new character and
persona five royal any signs of her
there's no signs of her in in the mp5s
yeah but I don't know I feels like maybe
like show cameo but I don't know if
she'll be like a core part of the story
given you know my name is I don't know
well how did you watch
I watched birds of prey I was not
excited for that movie talks I was like
it's a DC I mean my roommates been
watching all the DC movies
[Music]
we watched mine I was like I decided cut
I watched I watched the review of
Suicide Squad we obviously were kind of
fun easy yeah yeah and they are they
tore the movie up which it rightly
deserves I wish I recorded the moment on
Sunday where we were all hanging out in
our apartment and Greg goes today is
gonna be awesome like how friends around
Jen and alia cooking they made pizza
from scratch it was incredible they made
dill pickle pizza and it's the greatest
thing about him life I feel so
inadequate hearing about her cooking
skills the Ali plug for Ali's she runs
Andy's town well she works at Andy's
town and San Francisco so if you're
there and you want some incredible food
go anyway and Greg was like oh gonna
have pizza we're gonna have wings we're
gonna watch the Super Bowl
then we're gonna watch the outside it's
gonna be great and then he just his face
dropped and then he went I gotta watch
the Suicide Squad film it I think on
Monday they couldn't film on Tuesday
which is what they normally do and the
moment it was it was the Ralph Wiggum
you can almost see his heart and I was
like in the kitchen I was cleaning up
and stuff at least you wanna watch if
you want a lesson or like if you want to
see a movie that's obviously compromised
on a writing shooting editing standpoint
watch that film and it's an Academy
award-winning film what Academy Award do
you think it was costume makeup here is
and the costume makeup is not good but
birds-of-prey excellent film because
what was it up against that your
mother's huge out I remember yeah that's
like one but birds of prey is a very
very good film like it doesn't really
lean too hard on the you stuff like you
don't all you really need to know is
Harlequin was dating the Joker and it
begins with her breaking up with the
Joker and it's about her emancipation
good for her
this is like a like a really narrow is
the most narrative ly consistent movie
Warner Bros in DC have put out ever and
like that includes
Batman Superman no we're not talking
about I'm talking about like the EU yes
we don't even count it in the same
league it's I love that man it's so we
will not yeah party yeah is Tim Hardy
yeah but that movie is really really
good so it's the the narrative device
that they use is more like ambitious
than any of the other movies and at the
same time it manages to be like you
understand what the story is you
understand the motivations behind each
character even if they're somewhat like
ridiculous at times but that's kind of
the point with Harlequin and the group
of people that she kind of collects
together or or come together in their
movie it's not a team movie it's not
like she's put together the birds of
prey which is it he's MDC it's like
there's one central story and one
character and the but at the same time
there's other characters around this
story that have their own motivations
and it just so happens the story brings
them all together in a way that's
believable and it all kind of hangs on
Cassandra Cain who is you know she's a
well-known character and it comes back
oh who is this James Gunn direct yeah
this is an all-female
I'm gonna get I can't remember
director's name not because any reason
but not because it's fine I forgot yeah
so like that's the problem no problem
and that's the thing that I was gonna
that's the problem with this movie it's
like the so much of it has been focused
on Harlequin and Margot Robbie which is
fine like she's great in the movie but
like it's inserted by Kathy Yan but
there's so much more talent around it
that just didn't really win it and she's
she plays Huntress which is one of my
favorite characters in the DC Universe
McGregor is in this movie [ __ ] which of
his limited American accents is he doing
this one
he's doing his accents lips it's fine
it's lips when he gets angry and shouts
and then you're like I have the high
ground but like yeah like that's one of
the things that I found to be like ah
man I wish they had marketed this better
by talking about the director I didn't
know her name until like it came up on
screens and I promptly forgot it because
I'm bad with names but like that's a
problem with that movie like mary
elizabeth winstead it's amazing
i just want to say for the record that
I've been in love with her since high
school
thankfully she's amazing anything that
is true and then there's like Rosie
Perez is in it no she plays Renee
Montoya who if you know Gotham City PD
or any if you know Gotham City Impostors
well game can I help you yeah she plays
the Renee Montoya who's a pretty big
deal in the Batman universe murders of
Winstead there's like a bunch of like
there's Deena Lancers in this or black
Canary's in there the way it brings the
characters together is really like
believable and it's like a proper
popcorn blockbuster movie that you
should see in cinemas just cause this
rock
and it's like over the top in every way
it starts off feeling a bit try hard
because it's that's my fear from all the
marketing has been very it has intense
Suicide Squad energy to stop and you're
like oh I wish they'd like cuz it's
Margot Robbie's narrating in the movie
at the same time and like an event will
happen and then they'll be like Oh to
understand this we need to rewind to
this point yeah and they do that and
it's like alright starts off kind of
weird but then all the pieces come
together and there's some it's not I
don't I didn't find it funny personally
I found I could see the jokes were
appearing they weren't landing with me
but people around me or like like people
were loving and I was like go back to
England for those kalila but like it was
like edgy and like in a way that I think
like a movie crowd can get on with and
it had another thing that I had that I I
feel like was annoying me was it
retained the motion graphic sequences
from Suicide Squad which were put in
there to paper over the fact that a lot
of characters didn't have development
they develop basically just Deadshot in
Suicide Squad and no one else but and
Holly obviously cuz she's like one of
main stars and like it reminded me of
that but eventually I got past her and
it was like just a real fun film
Huntress is amazing the story is good
and it's like if you're if you're like
appropriately sourced up you could
probably have a good fun time laughing
ahead as well I was I was I was like
there and I spoke to brain effector kind
of funny folks again and II afterwards
and Nick and they were in the same
screen and they both agreed there was
fun and good I think it's easily the top
two movies in in a DC Shazam is good and
it's got the same kind of like
well-thought-out well-paced like
endearing quality to it it's slightly
more edgy and it's
anymore over the top but it's still a
good film yeah a good DC movie is a
rarity a blot a good blockbuster DC
movie is a rarity like Joker's fine but
it's not blockbuster it wasn't on a
blockbuster budget but they're there
they are a rarity and this is like
really really fun I would be surprised
if the another one doesn't come out with
this same squad or even more people this
suicide this birds of prey but yeah fun
film enjoy it go watch it I'm excited to
see it yeah basically has nothing to do
with the comics so yeah I'm okay with
that yeah I wouldn't know anyway yeah
Lucy I think all of us are playing a
little bit of this game but give it down
on your name and this little segue into
our next segment so yeah I've been
playing a lot of apex legends
I've been mostly playing with time oh
yeah a bunch times apex and I have a
weird relationship in that I know I
talked about overwatch all the time
overwatch is like my game because I'm
good at it and we win a lot when we play
because there's a group of us that play
every weekend and we we win a lot we're
very good watch apex is like me Tom and
Carter usually playing but because of
just the nature of apex you know when
you play overwatch there's two teams one
team will win 50% chance and chance
right in and then you get extra rewards
like to play the game and the medals the
cards at the end right apex doesn't give
me that immediate like satisfaction and
it doesn't give me the positive
reinforcement positive reinforcement
that I need because we don't win as much
in Apex
yes hard to win it's hard to win there's
a lot more people that you competing
against anyway that's my relationship
with apex so usually I go on tilts when
we play apex for a long time and then
I'm like I have to play overwatch like
three game on thanks yeah I wish I wish
I could say that I was less reliant on
winning but no I want I'm waving to with
Apex because I played a little bit last
night and
it because the game I mean the games are
much shorter than pub G for example
because those games are longer and every
time you restart it's like right I'm
starting fresh I'm starting with nothing
it's kind of hard to just keep going at
least for me at this point but part of
that is just because I played so much
pub G that kind of hit my limit with
Battle Royale I think that's fair but
with the assimilation so season four I
was kind of you know seasons we didn't
do anything for me I wasn't interested
in crypto I didn't even get Watson I
didn't get Maharaja [ __ ] a caustic
none of the legends other than octane
like post-release have really appealed
to me but going into a simulation I was
like this guy is Reaper mixed with Zarya
I want him and I bought I bought God I'm
gonna call him Reaper so many times I
bought revenant straight away cuz I had
amassed all these coins because I didn't
I don't buy anything in Apex because the
they've been getting better recently but
a lot of gunskins are like wow I think
player skin like the gunskins you
wouldn't spend your like weird apex
bucks on them just like so I had a bunch
and I just bought him immediately and he
is so fun to play yeah um he's really
kind of I'm thinking more about apex now
that I'm thinking about overwatch
which is a huge rarity and I think the
map changes a really fun but most of all
revenant I know I've said this on the
podcast before but I wish you could mute
characters in apex like he's very rude
I mean he's also Reinhardt's voice actor
which is very confusing for me because
you know you usually always have a
Reinhart at least on a payload map
anyway or a defense map anyway it's very
confusing and I keep one in the clone
Reaper but his moveset it's really fun
so he has this kind of his l1 is a it's
like a minis sorry a ground ball type
thing that damages you slightly but also
million people afire bilities which is
super useful his death toad
you know use abilities yeah yeah he he
has this death totem so if you want to
engage in a fight you can place it you
know just away from the fight interact
with it and then if you die you
immediately respawn back there but with
like 10 health or one health one use
it's one yeah like the circles closing
and it's outside the circle that you
leave or that your revenant leaves it in
and then you respond you'll just die
right away you know he moves faster he's
climbed higher he climbs higher further
faster he no he's just a lot of fun and
I it was kind of the shot in the arm
that I needed to get more into apex and
I think in my first game with him you
know usually have that weird adjustment
period but he just felt right yeah he's
got a lot of good like hassle I like his
Crouch walking speed is really fast yeah
I like being sneaky so I used that a lot
I think assimilations got a bunch of
other changes to it that are quite
impactful in how you play like sniper
ammo is now unique ammo yeah and I like
to have long what I like to have the DMR
longbow as a sniper rifle and then also
have a heavy weapon I can spit fire or
something like that because that's just
saying spit fire is great for that it's
always been my best gunner name when I
get that early on I can do incredibly
yeah but prior to this season they would
both use heavy ammo mm-hmm and that
means like ammo retention and also like
how you use it quite limited you have to
be very careful and if you use too much
of one and I got into a close quarters
from combat fight without we've known
how to pull out your Spitfire you might
have no enough ammo to really engage so
now they've split it out so a lot of the
sniper rifles use unique sniper ammo
which has made it way more appealing to
play that style that we would play so
that's been a massive change also
they've done things like there's a
hop-up that's been removed because I'd
like to have it
they've changed it having they changes
to the havoc is it has less horizontal
sort of rethink so yeah so is it gone
gone yeah is it the L star is now a just
a weapon that you can find anywhere
instead of a drop hot weapon yeah I use
that nose like this guns not as good as
a ton told him that I was told it was
because it's been nervous their changes
and it's not great the other thing is
like the certain characters that are
like they take more damage now Wraith
takes more revenue takes forty second
five percent yeah five percents revenant
Wraith lifeline yeah I think they look
they're like generally like harder to
hit characters they take more damage now
so also bloodhounds alts got buffed and
it's something like if you get more
kills so that you get a longer an enemy
down as a bloodhound extends the amount
of time you're in beasts of the hunt
there's it's insane this person is using
bloodhound and they just get I think
five knockdowns and then the win it's
bad news yeah it's yeah there's a lot
loads are like small tweaks to the way
the game plays that I've made it like a
little more interesting and engaging to
jump back in I think I'm the same as
Lucia I get annoyed after a while with
that game just because it's like ah
who's dropped in a place that's just not
good or you know if you're playing as a
- okay you're always stuck with someone
who's inevitably and in very jumpy so
well yeah or disconnect or just run off
somewhere else and do something or
engage in a fight that you can't win the
worst is when they die and you can heal
them and grab their tag and and they
quit before you do it it's like well or
they constantly spam they're like
respawn yeah but yeah I will say playing
last night after not playing for a while
I don't like that map at Worlds World's
End I don't like it's too big it will
focus on long-range I miss Kings Canyon
I know they're bringing it back what
March 24th so I think I'm gonna
definitely come back to it again when
that comes around but I think what I
played last
I was like that is probably all I need
of Apex for now unless they add
something else in between because I
really do miss Kings Kenny I thought
that map was really good yeah and
world's edge like has a world then has
some cool areas to it but just like
everything just seems so far apart for
that kind of style of Battle Royale like
with pub G it was like yeah everything
is felt like a mile apart but at least
in the original mouth I know I do see go
back to playing that Oh G I think there
the scavenging in that game was a bit
too intense for me game from scavenging
all day I playing like play apex it's
hard for me because I am just really
like slow battle royale so I have played
with like John Luke and Ben we were all
like what if we didn't drop spicy and we
dropped somewhere really safe and then
we got a bunch of gear and then we died
like in 15 minutes that'd be the best
and it was fun
that's just how I play like with pub G
to those firefights I feel Ike would
last so long because you could see each
other you knew where they were but you
didn't have any information other than
that and you just be in a town and you'd
be hiding in a building and you knew
they were hiding in a building but
you're like alright who's gonna make the
first move and then the circle would
force you to make a move and it was so
tense
I missed that game every day I haven't
played it in so long
in black ops for I will stand by
blackout being like Gaulish pub G you
know everything I wanted from pub G but
like it worked I I have a theory that I
think this next season of call of duty
modern warfare arts next week actually I
think I think there's gonna be a battle
royale map I think a battle royale map
was already leaked for this Call of Duty
game but I well make sure to call my dad
again and get his take on it yeah
official correspondent for Call of Duty
course fine Kenny's dad that's his dream
job yeah yeah it's just good I'm
enjoying a simulation like I I got the
one I got the character the same way and
then I spent the other of the three
virtual currencies to get like a cool
skin friend I'm like I'm good now what
is it's it's zero points it's
crafting I crafted a new skin and then
it's and it's like just a
microtransaction yeah yeah legend points
legend points which is the stupidest
thing but it's there I I do want to try
revenant I mean I very rarely strayed
from life line I was so comfortable
playing life line and it would be nice
to kind of branch out a little bit he's
loving
we were playing earlier and there was
that third random person and every time
you ping something revenant goes go
there now oh yeah I think I'm not gonna
thank you heal someone he's like I
shouldn't even heal you well at least
it's another target for there's
something like Jordan remain on our team
had a whole like sure fanfic in his head
about oh yeah gay dads Oh with who with
caustic let's yeah Jordans always crank
fanfic someone asked us if we could say
what beer we have so I figured this is
the grapefruit hop nosh which is not
spelled like this but it's like do
chutes so but it's a pilsner it looks
like a kid's good did you pour the diet
the brand I'm not gonna show that coke I
will show blood-borne good game listen
this is only 4% mmm so you know it's not
a bad thing that I've already had one
the goal with this podcast I think is
like well one of the many goals is that
if we start doing ads and stuff like
that read ads they should only be for
beer yeah we have to get that brand you
know drink responsibly drink responsibly
we at the company that makes us beer
where is it you do shoots you do Bend
Oregon which is we we have we have
insider we have some an Inside Man in
Bend Oregon
oh yeah tweet other company that makes
it best team to sponsor
News yeah so anyway more news last those
part two gets a spicy detailed rating
are we surprised well not for the
violence sorry actual the story here
isn't that it's an M a lot of us one got
em it's this script is that they use it
it's worth keeping in mind that these
are the time of like publishing the
details weren't finalized they could be
placeholder but usually they're a good
indication of what what's gonna be in
the game so the original last of us
there the game featured warnings for
blood and gore intense violence sexual
themes and strong language back on em
lots of us to go also got em but it's
got sexual themes
it's got intense violence it's got drug
use yeah he's gonna say I saw the drug
use in the demo partial nudity so those
are the main ones that are different so
it's way sorry intense violence blood
and gore nudie sexual content strong
language and use of drugs so it's like
hard em very mature how are the sexual
themes in the original last of us
blowers when she gets kidnapped in
winter it has a rapey vibe he's wrong in
themes
wrong in theaters I think some of this
stuff that the NPC said to was also like
sexual about that Louis yeah like the
bloody I'm gonna blow up about potential
rape intent in the game I often think
that the portrayal of rape in fiction is
not handled well and is unnecessary
do you think that's the case in I mean
it wasn't in I guess it wasn't lost to
us one means because it's implied in law
ways right I prefer to be implied rather
than explicit yeah yeah
I mean well I mean well yeah we'll see
like a benefit of the doubt I guess drug
use I bet is just weed oh yeah
so like in California were like okay
yeah it's gonna be a hard em please be
excited just change so much no I know it
what is this not February 27th this
month well I use that board in front of
us now oh yeah you've got I have a
special calendar just for me May 29 May
29th all right hey there is end of Mia I
don't like you when games come out at
the end of a month because then it's
like I gotta wait through the entire
month know what's coming out now I know
and now I'm bummed because the Animal
Crossing comes out March 20th and I'm
like I have to wait through all of
February and then almost all of March
playing will Karl's thing when it's like
couldn't you just really like it's
probably done knowing Nintendo can't you
just do like March J games early well
that's true but you know I've got no I
don't it's there is just like we're
gonna be so like it's gonna be like III
stress is rising I think I'm actually
going back to London at that time as
well I am do Tom the Tom's the postpone
it oh I've genuinely devastated myself
also we're probably gonna call this
episode two Moore's ps5 just I'm into it
I'll take that for the SEO bum I'll take
the hit the comments for the last of us
part tubes gonna be spicy oh yeah
I'm very excited again yes me too I love
the last of us I just want to plug my
lovely roommate Jen who she can't really
play open-world games because she gets
motion sick it was a horrible time for
all of us at the house she dry heaved
her way through the last of us because
she was so into it she'd just take
Dramamine to play it and Max and I were
just like sitting in the part of the
living room like please finish the game
soon well she'll be excited to hear that
this one is supposed to be the longest
game Naughty Dog has ever made she she
does better on the switch but it's not
coming to switch social just get the via
the treat is not dead plate loss of us
to anivia if she means she won't think
it's worth it yeah speaking of your
PlayStation 5 did you know they launched
a website about your console tomorrow I
do yeah it's the driest website I know
it goes like PS 5 and like yeah thanks
knowing I'll look they'll announce like
the PlayStation meeting before this well
actually there's a bit of text on there
on that website and it says we are no it
says um we're not ready to provide more
details and place it from five now so
there's been this rumor that's been been
kicked about for a while about a
February event for PlayStation 5 and the
rumor is like it's gone from like
slightly believable to like insane where
it's like oh it's gonna be it's gonna be
a February ball so they're gonna
announce Final Fantasy 16 and also
Demon Souls remaster is gonna be
released that that's like these Nintendo
Direct I feel like when in Tendo goes
long enough without having a Nintendo
Direct
everyone's like it's gotta be this week
other people and then I go on youtube
and it would just be like it would just
be like here's all my Nintendo Direct
predictions and it's like there's not
even a Nintendo Direct and now it's like
cut it out with your predictions and
also everyone always says Metroid
trilogy for their prediction and there
hasn't been a Metroid trilogy in the
past five directs even though that's
always their prediction I mean I think
Metroid Prime 3 will come I think it'll
happen yeah but you know Nintendo's
gonna Nintendo's Nintendo they'll wait
until every think the wait until
everyone's tired of like expecting it
and then they'll be like here it is and
it's out today and then I will cry yeah
but like there's some stuff that is in
that PlayStation first I'll tell you
like I can see it yeah I'm not saying
anything about anything I have no
information I have no information at all
so but yeah it's like they're definitely
not doing a it doesn't seem like they're
doing a kind of like a surprise event
soon anyway because a lot of their
people do their because they did it for
the PlayStation 4 was like in New York
and the Sony senator flying people over
to see etc etc that's too much of a big
thing for to pull off in a week so yeah
not happening so yeah that website stay
if you want to look at a PlayStation 5
logo in another place come to Tom's desk
if you want look if you want to see the
actual PlayStation or five hit me up
I'll tell you you can't see it yeah
Jim's are open right games open ops me
if you want the PlayStation 5 I'll send
you a picture
if you DM me and also a PlayStation 5
I'll send you a picture um a picture
yeah he didn't specify
in other news dan Houser leave leaves
Rockstar Games which took me by surprise
yesterday because for some background
dan Houser is credited to writing every
single GTA game even like the PSP games
even like the DS games like chinatown
wars and stuff like that as well as
bully max
Payne 3 Red Dead Redemption Red Dead
Redemption - I think even like one of
the Midnight Club games as well so he's
had table tennis
he wrote the story and then he did write
the story action brother ping and then
the pong it's like here's the script
it's like 500 pages like and then just
loads of dead trees and pong on the end
that's wild oh I didn't expect him and
then and then the note that said that
he'd gone was like took an extended
leave spring last year I was like my man
has worked on some of the biggest games
of all time yeah yeah that's fair yeah
well I mean I feel very normal right
especially like you're gonna take a long
break after you ship a game like that at
least if your that's that yeah oh I
imagine you can but like I cannot
picture what GTA 6 would look like
without him and I don't want to like
that means I'm still that Sam is still
there but he does he's a lot of like
chief producing in like business side
right and like I don't want to say that
he's the only one who makes those games
because it's not he's one person of a
massive team but still it that that idea
I feel like you can kind of follow
through all of them you kind of trace
back to him I would say yeah I mean like
he's that that kind of way of like
finishing a game and then having an
extended break and then just quietly
trying to disappear and not trying to
because I dropped it in like a mega dry
like like financial document that
information and yeah that kind of
process was the same thing I haven't -
Leslie Benzies
the ban yeah the bends and happens a lot
of like senior executives in that same
way but there was a like there was an
interesting like quote a little while
back about them talking about how
they're gonna make GTA 6 and they were
saying like we do not know how we're
gonna make it because like Politico
sucks like politics right now is such a
joke and it's like both sides of the
fence are so like a parody of themselves
that oh yeah just like Donald Trump was
the president in all of the GTA games
yeah and now it's like oh he is
and like that's the problem that a
that's the problem they face not the
world that they satire is almost our
world have the same yeah I don't doubt
that there will be a gta6
but like I'm interested see what that is
but like on it
we're in the stage of like you can't
write this [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
impeachment results today by the way if
you were wondering your timeframe if I'm
recording this but I like shout out to
him he's going out on one having had a
major role in the best-selling game of
this generation and then of all time
right yeah I think Red Dead Redemption 2
is like a very good game to go out on
especially for saying when you track
like the themes of his games and how
they all kind of let up of their games
and led up to Red Dead Redemption to
like it it's almost poetic that that
would be his last game to be a part of
yeah at least rockstar game didn't think
of it that way I was think about that
and I was like that makes sense and
honestly like I don't know where you'd
go from there like the expectations for
GTA 6 are probably insane they are
insane yeah I mean if anyone can put
office then just all they want for GTA 6
is strippers gone rogue basically it's
not a bad idea
definitely pitch this before on podcast
is like I want to be the stripper who
gets information at work mm-hmm and uses
that for crime
that's the GTA I want so that it just
you know Rockstar if you're listening
like that's where you go from here but
like that's just that's just me like
hustlers but GTA so that's free you can
have that for free yeah wait maybe we
should get some royalties well actually
you think you could pay me for that that
idea bully to was what I figured they'd
follow up with because of how big red
dead redemption is how long that took to
make I figured everyone wants a bully to
so bad or a lot of people want a bully
to so bad and I think I feel like that
would be the perfect game to go back to
just because it's by nature a lot
smaller and
probably shorter sprawling university
campus yeah I reckon they just take a
Jimmy and put him in like an actual GTA
sighs game way he's a full-on criminal
and he Jimmy is just the star of the
next sheet here that would be a rock
star thing that'll be disappointing
though cuz like because non strippers
well that and like the thing I kind of
took away from Bowie was that Jimmy
wasn't actually a bad kid he was like
trying to be better and just a lot of
circumstances that game is my mom calls
me Prince LG let's see all right here
constantly playing their game oh my gosh
Elgin I'm pleased okay it's good the
music is really good is one of the
themes when the main themes is
frequently used in hip hop remixes it's
very good background bass
speaking of big departures though Rod
Fergusson leaves the coalition to head
up the Diablo franchise Blizzard Rod
Fergusson gets games shipped yeah he's
clearly going for the yeah the finals
he's the fixer I was gonna say something
like the final bits of Diablo for he's
probably he's he's got a reputation I
was gonna make a terrible joke do it
yeah he's got a reputation for
like getting projects on ok door out the
door he did it with BioShock Infinite
and like he's done it with a bunch of
games
well we when we were talking to him for
audio logs he was like yeah we had 18
months to ship the original schism
alright you you don't get that done
unless you have a producer yeah keeping
everyone's task mm-hmm audio logs the
last filmed interview Ferguson as a head
of the coalition what you know that's
what I am but yeah that's I think that
that bodes well for
diablo as a franchise and Blizzard I
mean like he's known as the fixer but I
think that that kind of reputation and
is kind of under sells what he does he's
also great at having a creative vision
and pushing new ideas which is what he
did at the coalition it's like under his
stewardship like the gears franchise
like left DOM and Marcus behind and I
mean they're still in the games and you
know bed and those guys but it's like a
new generation started to move into a
semi open-world vehicular kind of
movement that kind of stuff so he does
have ideas and he's able to take ideas
and execute on them as well so him going
to Blizzard helps Diablo 1 both get out
the door but he's there to look after
the Diablo franchise he's not there to
ship Diablo 4 he's there as like his
role at the coalition was like head of
the studio that is in charge of Gears of
War now his head of Diablo so future
Diablo titles should be interesting or
have a more coherent vision which is
what they kind of need now given the
recent problems with Blizzard and I mean
the recent problems with blizzards are
way more than just what Diablo is not to
be reductive around that kind of stuff
but like Diablo has had a bit of a
optics issue shall we call it with that
mobile game and also you know dude I'm
what offer it I mean I don't think
there's been an outright bad Diablo game
ever and Blizzard still has hasn't put
out a tour may almost is not great but
yeah there's more to why that's not
great then simply the game is bad yeah
the game is functional and it works and
it's enjoyable in some respects it's
just stuff around it so like I've got
enough faith in the developers of that
game to pull out a decent game Diablo
project yeah well I mean what's
interesting too is being at Blizzcon and
after all this stuff about Diablo 4
when everyone's like when's this game so
Scott they're like oh we don't know it's
like you know like Rod Fergusson ships
games right like I mean maybe that all
shorten the timeline or maybe you know
you know give us something more concrete
like yeah hang our hat on about when
Diablo four well actually Wow
yes leave Canada though he's a very
Canadian boy from what I could tell
that's gonna make him sad probably
before we move on to listening questions
can I just add in a new story that we
haven't written down here but that I
would like just to commit everyone doing
new stories one gamespot.com is that
cliff Basinski still working on his book
that story's ridiculous and like oh god
but he released a couple pages from his
memoir like three years ago and he's
scrubbed them from the internet but
every so often he tweets that he's still
working on it there was nothing more
that I want in this life than to read
that comes out I am immediately adapting
it into a video series feel like on the
team it's me you Chris P and Eddie are
just like with where's the book because
he's been to publishers and they say
that it's like he's working on it I just
want to know what a video game
development my MA
for someone who's had a career and a
life story I mean the dude put out some
good games yeah I just hope it has no
sexual content those transcripts have
been but he tweeted about giving it to
his publicist and his publicist
described it as what it's like oh what's
that Anthony Bourdain's books cannot
wait I'm kind of overwhelmed by this
yeah well I read that don't
that's my I'm dead I'm not not read it
tell you right now I'm gonna highlight
the choice quotes and just like repeat
yeah I am is very off-topic but I just
started reading Kanye West doesn't he
$300 at at your recommendation it's good
isn't it the first Chaplin read the
first chapters and that's good yeah so
Banga you know so it's about a guy who
used to be on a podcast called get up on
this hmm
and at one point in time he was the
hottest rapper in America he was like
Carl
I'll call he went under that name Hawk
call which is maybe not a good name and
yeah he recounts how he got that bad
name and he's like this is a bad name
and I know it's bad but it's all I could
do but I own it yeah yeah but I'm gonna
own it but he was like one of the most
well known and aggressively like good
bow rappers and they used to have this
like ongoing radio show where people
would phone in and do a deal about rap
and he's I believe still go he had the
record for like most consecutive wins
and he got all the way to the point of
like he's worked with Missy Elliott
where he worked with like Busta Rhymes a
bunch of well-known hip hop IIST
he got to the point just before making
it big and then failed and then this is
his story about how he got to that point
and his experience at that point and
it's called Kanye West owes me $300 but
it's fascinating and it's not like he's
way actually starts with him almost
dying yeah it's like but it's he's not
like bitter about it he's just like I
had a run and it was fun and it's like
and then I went on to you know just do
other things he's he's fairly from
Woodland Hills yeah yeah so he was like
his whole story was like I was the only
person that enjoyed rap music and battle
rap and like you know he's from an area
which is like now it's Calabasas well
yeah so he went to school in Calabasas
from what I read but he is his family's
from would lay there like
yeah so yeah it's a it's a really good
interesting fun breezy read yeah I read
quite a bit this morning it was easy to
get through his entertain just for
context Calabasas is where the
Kardashians and there is a gated
community in Woodland Hills that has
like 24/7 security and it's where rich
famous people live sorry in Calabasas
and then Woodland Hills is like diet
Calabasas yes so he talks about what
Woodland Hills in Calabasas are now and
talks about how it was back then where
he was the outsider for liking rap music
and like had to find the people to
battle and that's how he became one of
the best pal rappers it was like he was
aggressively looking for battles and is
also an episode episode a story about
almost Kim blown up by grenade weight in
the spoilers that happens in the book
anyway moving right on to listener
questions wants to take the first one
I'll say this one cuz I brought this
thing up this is from Joe in Seattle
hey team listening to episode 26 uh oh
wait we should plug the email address oh
yeah and if you have questions please
email us that after I don't know if
camera to look at oh look at that one
please email us that after dark I did I
stopped looking at right when I read it
I looked at me please email us email us
and after dark podcast at gamespot.com
take it away hey team listening to
episode 26 y'all brought up Cormac
McCarthy's the road
I just realized I've been staring sadly
a wolf for like five minutes thinking
about it yeah that book ruins you ever
had a game and give you that the road
feeling or just strong sad feels The
Last of Us seems like an obvious truce
with me though I never finished it that
one moment Inc is - I think where dom
finds his wife is another one
thanks it's from joe in seattle it's a
cliffy B game uh for me in Mass Effect 3
where I thought grunt was dead I
was in floods of tears it immortan yeah
well I mean I've told us in the pockets
for I accidentally saved him and I was
like what you guys complaining about Wow
super specific three yeah but I got
those war credits
[Music]
I have clinical depression so most
things Tetris I guess I I don't know
whenever I think about ready redemption
I oh yeah actually that's a the ending
of read that one yeah also read dead 2
and read there are some moments in
residue like render to though at least
the ending was like more optimistic yeah
any but that one was like crushing Jesus
yeah
jean-luc just talked in the intercom and
scared the [ __ ] out of Lucy which is
going to switch and PC on February 13th
just in time for Valentine's Day
right so much playing Florida yeah it's
like what an hour and a half hour if you
wanna Valentine's Day pick that game up
and you can play with eyes and crushing
lows of a relationship in one hour
mm-hm enjoy it's great there's various
moments in Metal Gear Mel gay three
obviously stands out but you have to at
the end take yeah
I cried for about 20 minutes after
finishing death stranding just that's
like a just everything I don't know yeah
yeah does funding hmm what else this
like what this gen has made me yeah I
don't think anything yeah yeah I think
that surroundings a good one yeah you
you kind of you exist in that kind of
like melancholy for so long yeah I mean
if you really mess up in The Witcher 3
and you make some bad decisions and bad
things happen to Siri that's pretty bad
I was like you got the yeah didn't make
me cry though I just I just sat and went
ah yeah I could see it like it like
flashes back to all the points we could
have done something better and and it's
just like I'm a bad dad Oh wild sorry
didn't finish it I'm doing I think
there's probably some like the road
moments in death yeah I I am actually
playing plague tale right now but I
don't know if his road not vibes it's go
Road vibes jean-luc forgot to after we
caught a shiny Snorlax jean-luc forgot
to save so he lost the shiny Snorlax
that's like maybe he's crying right now
a lot of stuff makes me sad
that's really good no I know you saw
that puppy via or that dog the other day
hi there was a dog in the office and
look trooper trooper yeah and I went to
pet the dog and then I walked away and
the dog kept staring at me and then I
began to cry he was an old an old boy of
rescue and he had a big bandana around
they said adopt me they put three bins
in his way and he was like well I'm
stuck here for long go open downstairs
he's so old
and just to block him off from walking
around the office they put bins and he
was just like
foiled again in an area where he could
look through meeting room doors mass
effect Legion have a soul that gets me I
was like my dog is 12 and in good health
and sometimes I think about her die and
I cry you're not my dog
the next question is for you so I'm
going to read it answer it
hey everyone but mostly Kali I've been
reviewing games for an indie site and I
was wondering what your advice was for
pitching freelance reviews to GameSpot
this is from Sam Harrison he's written a
couple times friend of the show Kelly
it's me Sam how do I be dead man so I
liked this question because I do get
pitches for specific reviews but
actually I think the best way to pitch
to us at least is to pitch your review
expertise in general your skill with
writing reviews what genres and
platforms that you can confidently cover
because for me I'm not looking for
individual reviewers I'm looking for
long-term like you review games as a
freelancer for GameSpot so for me those
are the kinds of pitches I'm looking for
is is hi I am a reviewer here are some
samples these are the kinds of games I
like to review I do look for like a
diversity in expertise so like I get a
lot of people who like narrative based
indie games and the sad fact is that
everybody likes those and I have too
many people who are good at reviewing
those um sports games that's where it's
asking the more niche you are the I mean
like this isn't to say that liking
popular things and being good at
reviewing them isn't useful but
for X Games like really hardcore
strategy games think like like more like
more than civilization
you know universe on this exactly like
the really hardcore strategy games like
nish RPGs and sports are like the the
hardest things to assign but yeah I mean
I'm looking for reviewers who are
dedicated to critique who are good
writers first and foremost I think the
mistake a lot of people when they're
starting out in this industry make is
being like oh I play anything like I
love games and it's like no no why do
you like criticism why do you like
writing criticism what is your writing
skill and then what specifically do you
enjoy writing about so specificity is
something I look for in an overall pitch
and and like I said I'm taking pitches
for like long term like I'm doing
reviews in general rather than specific
games it does take a little bit to
onboard people so I can't like if the
game is coming out tomorrow yeah I can't
take your pitch because I can't get you
into the system where you would get paid
so I used to like occasionally I'd take
pictures as well for when I was doing
stuff more in the UK and I would always
ask like what's coming up that you are
interested in that's a good thing to do
as well I mean your patient Callie more
than me now these days but like a list
of things that's coming up but
importantly I used to get people who are
like hey yeah I'm interested in the last
of us too and you're like come on man
that's gonna be like somebody yeah think
about whether like we trust our
reviewers but we also want to make sure
that certain games are reviewed by a
core member of staff because everybody
here does root-like reviews reviews it's
not just a freelance thing and there are
big games that people want to review
here but yeah I do really like getting
the here's what I'm interested in over
time in the next month in the next two
months because that helps me if I'm
looking at a list
Gamze eh what are my reviewers
interested in reviewing because I might
not have that game on my radar you know
or be like what are my choices when I'm
faced with a game that nobody on staff
is knowledgeable and or interested in
okay who on my freelance team can I can
I lean on for this so yeah those those
things are important also don't live in
California right the law is very weird
yeah yeah Californian particular right
is pretty tricky with onboarding
freelancers isn't it it can be I mean a
b5 is the law so mm-hmm
yeah but that doesn't like precluded
it's just a little tricky but I
definitely am taking pitches mmm like I
said general pitches mmm if you and I
should clarify I don't take like oh I've
never reviewed a game but I want to
unfortunately that's just not something
that we as a site can do if you have
experience at other sites if you have a
portfolio of work definitely do that and
then if you are interested in writing
reviews but you've never done it
definitely look at small sites and pitch
reviews that way or even write reviews
like on a blog on your tumblr like just
get some body of writing that's what I
did I actually just wrote a blog review
kind of things and as a freelancer I
mostly did reviews but I would say like
I mean it's it it's an interesting
reviews aren't interesting beasts so
there are a good time and then I would
say the last thing is if you're
interested in reviewing a game for
GameSpot definitely read game bus pot
reviews to get a sense of what our style
is I think that's also challenges people
having a different idea of what the
purpose of a review is so if you just
read some some GameSpot reviews
I am very attentive in editing I am
proud of every review that goes on the
site I sign off on every single one so
anyone can be an example for you to read
and see like this is kind of what the
idea is
does it count as reading if I scroll to
the bottom and look at the score no okay
I just wanted you know I'm sure some
people may be thinking that someone
asked them before you've written read
some reviews Lucy has to do yeah we're
not even writers knows yeah that's why
that's why I said that
oh some more review [ __ ] all day long
love reviews I I do but
they take a lot of time not fifty hour
games in one day bargains like sec euro
holy moly yeah I like reading reviews I
don't like when I published them in it
because have a clue for me I mean like
we like the last year was a rough like
review like was it Sakura was rough for
me and Kingdom Hearts but then you have
like death stranding I did never doing
call of duty again I am saying that here
on air
I'm never reviewing color TV again
somebody else can do that I'll review
Sakura again what have a blood-borne
again I'll review tonight and
blood-borne Kelly do you wanna take the
next one sure yeah after dark crew I've
been listening since episode one and
loved every scene everything since thank
you my question for you all is immoral
time I go to play a massive game in the
vein of The Witcher 3 and breath the
wild I always start out strong we
quickly fall off because of their
daunting scope here's my question
do any of you have the same problem if
so do you have any advice on how to
overcome this so I can finally play
these amazing games keep up the amazing
work Tanner from Evansdale Iowa Thank
You tanner yes I get distracted really
quick I fall off really fast um it helps
to just stick to the critical path for a
while
for a while and then once you realize
that oh maybe this side quest looks like
looks interesting I want to go explore
that or maybe there's a collectible that
I want to go for try and do it that way
and hopefully that the the main path the
main story I'll get its hooks in you and
you'll want to keep going with it but no
I totally feel that because some games
they just offer just so much and you're
like I don't know if I have the time all
the energy of the willpower to do it or
you're like I'm gonna spec into the
wrong thing and then 20 hours in I'm
gonna think I need to restart or you're
gonna be my roommate who's like I think
I missed a quite card I don't know what
to do
me where I just I'm lucky that I'm
friends with Jake because then I would I
would never have played The Witcher and
because I'd be like I don't even know
who dandelion his help
so having friends that know things about
the game can be helpful Dragon Age
Inquisition what's go like I doubt the
problem with that one was it was unclear
what the main path was yeah people were
like I remember we had to publish an
article which was leave the first area
immediately
because that stuff it's just time
wasting time wasting area and stick to
the main part I think that Assassin's
Creed Odyssey is also a great game but I
think it has some of that Dragon Age
Inquisition hinterland the games got a
lot of fat yeah Wow I was picturing
Super Mario Odyssey for a second but and
I was like that one's not in although
unless you try to get all the what are
they there's like 700 or some absurd
number but life I find sticking to the
main path and also like not trying to
binge play it so I like I'm surprisingly
like I fell off I had this issue with
the first Mass Effect yeah and like I
got it day one like actually I think I
self broke the street because I was
working on a staff discount earlier I
was like late fools and like I started
playing it and I couldn't get into it
and I kept getting distracted and then I
realized like oh it's a kind of a slow
start to begin with overwhelming and
then like I found the other thing I
recommend is like you just have to be in
a good like a specific mood sometimes to
get into it you have to be ready to
accept a big game into your heart other
time and that means like not having -
distractions and I remember I got into
Mass Effect after I had like completed I
think I can assignment or something and
like got into like this like darkened
room sat down like headphones on and
then like I think I played when I got
into it I played like 12 hours straight
and then that's what it's like just
sometimes you have to accept that you're
not in the mood for
you just can't do it but if that's
because you got kids is a distraction or
something else that is on your mind like
don't try and force it when you deep
down probably know now's not the right
time to play that place nothing small I
think a lot of us do that way we'll play
we'll get ready for something big or
come off we'll get ready for a big game
or like decompress for my big game by
playing loads of small experience or
like something smaller like you can do
that that's fine I would say also like
with breath of the wild in particular I
think that's a game that's designed to
like there's no path you're gonna take
that's gonna get you totally lost like I
think something I think some of the
games that are critically acclaimed or
critically claim for a reason and those
are the games that are not gonna leave
you hanging so it can be easier said
than done but maybe keep in mind like
you know what I'm just gonna follow
where I'm curious and this game is going
to reward me for that and then I'll keep
going so I think breath of the wild is a
fantastic example of that
I even think like on a smaller scale
like disco Elysium is a game that if you
just follow where you're curious that
game will carry you through but at first
your money unless you're Mike then that
game can at first be very overwhelming
but if you just are like you know what
the bookstore seems cool that's all you
need
and I think breath of the wild it's just
a much bigger version of that you're
like that's a pretty place to go and you
go there so that can help - is like
letting go of like for me a big problem
with these games is perfectionism like
I'm gonna spec into the wrong thing or
actually like I restarted kotor so many
times to respec at the beginning i easy
came to restore over and over again
either I really enjoy the character
building part of that game of games like
that but just being like you know what
unless I'm playing on the hardest
difficulty this game is not gonna punish
me for likes pecking into a weird thing
unless like there is an article on
gamespot.com that tells you to not do a
certain almost certainly will be
I think outer worlds was good for that
like it was
really it's a game that feels big but
actually is quite contained and if you
follow the main path you get pretty much
everything you would want out of that
kind of experience out of it and if you
are worried about things like specking
the respect stations available maybe 10
minutes into the game 15 minutes is a
game and it doesn't like really punish
you super hard for respecting a bunch of
time so I hope there's more games like
that kind of more like time cognizant
and making sure that you know they're
designed in a way that facilitates
people like that I also think it's ok to
just like not finish games oh you're not
feeling it latest it's fine I do that a
lot honestly because if a game doesn't
draw me in pretty early on I have a very
hard time continuing it especially like
where we're at now right like it's
there's so many games that were expected
to play and I'll play a lot of games
just to see if it's my kind of thing and
if it's not my thing I will fall off and
I used to feel bad about that
probably because I didn't I was I was in
college and I was trying to pay for
these games and when I got a game I was
like I got to play all of this I gotta
make every cent count so I guess we're
fortunate in that like if there's a game
that I'm playing and I'm like everyone
likes it and I play an hour like yeah
it's not for me I can just drop it but I
will say even then like even when I was
in school and stuff like that if a game
style didn't like pull me in right away
especially for longer games there's a
good chance that I just wouldn't do it
like I always I I couldn't get on board
with Assassin's Creed games for the most
part even though I got them probably
because like I don't know the story just
didn't grip me ever except for I
finished I finished three oddly I don't
know why I finished the wrong of all of
them yeah I really liked Odyssey and our
black flag those are the two that I was
the most of Assassin's Creed II am I
played but yeah I would say for the most
part like there are a lot of games that
I just fall off right away but then
there's games like The Witcher 3 which I
played four or five times and I'm just
like like I don't need to play this game
anymore but that world is just so
engrossing and I imagine similar
four or five times it's it's like five
and a half but I'm sure the same thing
is gonna happen with like cyberpunk
right because that world I'm already
super into like like I said before I
think about Animal Crossing on a daily
basis dude deep pocket news is the best
Twitter account just like there's a bike
in the background of this promo art can
you write it and I'm like I would love
to know I love that I love just Animal
Crossing like fan accounts on YouTube
and stuff like that because they cling
on to the weirdest stuff now they get so
excited about the stupidest things like
it's just like it's so wholesome who are
used to being the other day who's like
never been into Animal Crossing but I've
just discovered this whole subset of
froggy chair memes
[Music]
I'm glad the switches so I'm glad
because it was in my car I know you did
that's what that's why I was like I want
it I went on to Best Buy and I put it in
my car and I was like oh it's gonna take
the money now it's January my dude money
let me buy MCR tickets let me buy this
switch what's money I was gonna buy him
see our tickets and then I said Kurt was
trying to get them for us and he was
like uh the pit is two hundred and fifty
dollars it tickets like I'm good I have
extras if you want eighty dollars a
ticket
oh I could do that okay let's talk after
thank you
two more I think it's you you want to do
last one a longest one hi everyone
Jeff from Nashville here my wife and I
recently started watching bough star
Galactica yes it's my second full time
through in her first
it's an incredibly well-written
character drama and some of the best
world building I've seen in a show it
works so well in fact I recently noticed
my coworker regularly saying frak at
work you mate he's been saying it so
long that he forgot it came from the
show I heard that and God's a lot from
other fans of the show
my questions are twofold d any of you
have shows you've picked up slang from
if so which shows and which was I seem
to remember Lucy was a big fan of the
show for some we see tweets bounce up
so this one is for her and anyone else
who has seen it all of us have you know
a grip
have you noticed how little Gaius Baltar
blinks what he doesn't blink that much
it's part of his intensity yeah I can't
find anything on the internet about it
but good lord that man is a hundred
percent until the entire show he
absolutely is like he'll episode 1
almost complete annihilation you're all
awesome thanks for all you do Jeff
so Jeff I want to let you know that when
I was in college I took a Battlestar
Gallactica class for credit um it was I
had already seen the show and then I
took the class on it where we would
watch episodes in class and then it
would be like so what about God and I'd
be like yeah like bow was the whole
class it was sick
33 is one of the best episodes of - OH
incredible character I never thought
about the blinking thing though I think
it was like part of he's just playing
the character so well yeah hi I've been
watching The Office and the only thing
that comes in mind about Battlestar
Galactica is I went through a phase of
saying frak I think if you watch well so
glad to hear you kind of all you both
what is frak is like Oh frak is their
way of swearing yeah
because if you think about the the world
in which the characters Battlestar
Galactica live is that like the robot
upright like very reductive but the
robot uprising existed and humanity is
essentially on the run they have nothing
they have like no food no fuel they're
just on ships in space how are you not
gonna be swearing through that at all so
they they've come up for the sanitize
they make up the runs well yeah because
what it was like a Warner Bros that we
be sure one thing I really like about
the world building in that show is all
the pieces of paper have the corners cut
yes yes I love that tags to just
remember the overweighted all my it
really rivals except fat Mac he actually
did put the weight on a really bad
perspective so I actually watched today
because Stephen Colbert you know the the
Colbert show finds TV oh yeah Viacom CBS
property Rob Mackel and he came on that
show I think a couple days ago and he
talked about the fat about fat Mac and
he was like yeah in friends I noticed
how everyone just kept getting nicer and
nicer because they had more money so I
want to do the opposite and I just
wanted to get I just wanted to like
destroy my body and that's what he did
yeah and and Stephen Colbert was like so
which one did your wife white wife like
more the ripped Mac or the fat back and
he's like the fat nak because I was
jolly all the time we should probably
answer the question do you have any
shows you've picked up slang from if so
which shows and what words not specific
slang but I reference Arrested
Development all at the point now where
it's unconscious I just don't even
realize people ask me how I'm doing or
something and I will just say it's good
it's going to be good like I just I love
Rob and I do that all the time
I went through
marry me phase yeah scrubs is mine
scrubs like I say I say I'm Brenna III
you're I refer to Brenna as an actual
meal breakfast when I was home visiting
my parents a couple months ago there was
a dead bird in the fridge I was like I
was like I don't know why I asked like I
don't get it like never mind
wait why was there dipp'd they explained
to me I don't remember because I was
just think about it I was just thinking
about arrest develop Michael yeah I
think it was because my mom found a bird
and it died pretty quickly and she
didn't know what to do with it she
frozen put it outside
well no it was a lot it was alive at the
time and did you put in the fridge no no
I don't know I don't know so anyway all
I know is that there was like a
Tupperware and there was dead bird in
there and I was like the [ __ ] so well
now you gotta bleep that out
no [ __ ] I do a lot of Simpsons not
specifically lines for years but I'll be
like all just in the middle of things be
like oh that's just like the Simpsons
episode where Bowl perfectly crow
mewling perfectly I was gonna say I like
Crom Yulin I use common I using begin
and bigan yeah and then I I'll do the
always sunny I'm eating because I'm very
uncomfortable and then they like take a
five yeah it's a mic Mahadi yeah no yeah
it's mostly just we quote things we
quote a lot of vines we did that on the
episode already I do thanks a lot
I don't even say so no Mikado it's just
the inflection on thing
[Music]
while driving you know I got a do a road
work ahead yeah I sure hope it does he
has a really good YouTube channel drew
garden where he does like video essays
about stuff he did a really good one
about Logan Paul he does a lot about
Logan Paul
um but heels did stuff like the office
that's very good what have you got in
your hand a knife no yeah I really the
office had such an incredible impact on
that's what she said Joe yeah just
groundbreaking really so watch the
episode with him when when Michael's
trying to be serious and Jim's like wow
it must been really hard right and
Michael's is like you've always left me
smiling and satisfied I also do I feel
God in this Chili's tonight yeah watch
that episode as well
Futurama actually for me yeah I was just
thinking um I've been watching it again
recently because I want to see the live
shows much skating acts let me axe you
again yeah we should I doing that
yeah Levi was doing that and we watched
the episode where Roswell begin again
when she's like let me ask you again
also the fight I'm my favorite running
joke and Futurama is that owls are pests
[Laughter]
which is your favorite good news
everyone
oh that I would actually need to really
think about that I've been think about
doing a Futurama rewatch always good on
Hulu it's very good - good news everyone
you're not good enough to go on your
next mission
you know what got worn out really well
really quickly by the internet
unfortunately was the shock to my money
hookers oh yeah I saw that one I I cheat
no no and say what I use all the time
which is related to blackjack and
hookers it's a shuttle baby I know it
you know from tick-tock we've been doing
Wow didn't know it did that you know
what no stealing only data but it is
good yeah yeah but no did not notice
that about guys Walter also Alucard in
Castlevania just coming back he's one of
my top twitter follows me too
he followed me because when we were
doing GameSpot Thrones the HBO store
sent us a little three-eyed raven and i
called mine guys Baltar because I was
like oh Game of Thrones is going down
this weird path where it's like all of
this has happened before and all this
will happen again and so I called him
guys Baltar and then someone i tweeted
that and then someone tagged him in when
he followed me mine was Fania very nice
he's very pleasant online online
profiles that sounded weird but like
he's good on to it I was just I was
really a proponent of Katee Sackhoff as
captain captain Marya she was fine if
you are watching heard Battlestar
Galactica may I recommend the Battlestar
Galactica yeah which helped Tricia
Helfer and Mark Barnard in Mach
Bernardin's on Kevin Smith's like
podcasts and he co-hosts she's never
seen the series she's only seen bits of
it and she's obviously in it for the
entire thing but like they watched the
show back together and she like relays
things that she you know obviously
experienced in the production of their
and they bring in like a sack off and
they
bringing various members of I love that
her in case a crow for such good friends
yeah do they do like the guy who play
sold hi comes on and it is sold hi do
they do like an podcast episode per
episode of television like yes I mean
that's how it started I'm like a few I'm
not quite far behind because I had to
move countries while that was starting
up so it's like I lost track of it but I
believe it was like an episode and then
they'll do or like a couple of episodes
oh you were gonna watch these episodes
I'm gonna discuss them have you guys
seen the Battlestar Galactica bit on
Portlandia yes that was me with Ozzy uni
because I just box at house in college -
yeah I like remember watching it like on
my laptop for hours yeah like go to bed
at 6 a.m. I did the exact same thing I
watched I remember the first season and
then I told my roommate Ellie and I was
like me you've gotta get on this and
then I lent it to her and it was this
weird tandem thing where we would go to
them
wasn't my voice and then we would go to
computer exchange cex who are now
stylizing themselves as sex which is
okay so it's a secondhand shop in the UK
we buy DVDs and games and stuff and I
would go and we would buy the box set
and then whoever bought it would watch
it first and then you pass the disc to
the other person
why sure why sure I told myself I would
wear it for this episode
I knew this question was gonna be here
but I have to bow start Galactica's
shirts I asked a dude the tank top with
Viper or Viper pilot and then I have a
Cylon spine shirt which is my [ __ ]
Battlestar Galactica shirt I have like
the Starbuck tags which is the only I
don't have a t-shirt I did want to go
with Starbuck for Halloween one yeah we
could do a group we could dibs on a
dollar yeah also one of the best uses of
licensed music and TV
[Music]
if you want to see you execute it's like
last episode of the fire season if you
also listen to the box I got to get
soundtrack there is a song called
Battlestar sand sonata Co
something-something on that which is
like this beautiful instrumental you
would love bowels may you really no no I
said McCreary who do about Reaper and
doctrine ation means sure I would it's
so good you should watch it my favorite
movies but if you watch it masters worth
of episode if you're taking a class that
mean if you watch it on Netflix I think
they put the movies in yeah because
there's what about Pegasus and there's
the plan like you will I think you'll
really dig like it's once you start you
don't start you really don't stop it's
it's a banger have you seen the picture
of the guy who played the original
Starbuck with Katee Sackhoff a Starbuck
in a Starbuck yeah no yeah what they
went they went like viral a while back
here you understand the only thing I was
gonna add is that Mike and I talked
about starting a podcast about It's
Always Sunny where we do an episode of
the podcast for each episode of It's
Always Sunny but we didn't know how we'd
get through season one because I still
like three episodes because I was like
ways this man in 2009 or whatever it
came out I've seen the nightmare pieces
of art I've seen that watch it was me
you and Mason I was like guys there's a
whole channel she put it on in
immediately for the sleep first of all I
haven't I have an mo and that is to put
something on them and I was enjoying it
Mason was like yeah she's asleep
I watched season one again fairly
recently and
it's still right yes I'm sure I'm sure
it's hilarious you just I just don't
know how I like this is three or four
years ago Mike Mike and I were like well
we just skipped like the first season or
something like that I mean some episodes
like even the episode tiles you can't
you bet you he would have some what I
love to get Rob McIlhenny on here and
then what would be my dream you saw he
was hanging out with Stephen Colbert
it's up the chain Stephen Colbert but I
would I would die if we had him on I
only died - yeah I just you know what I
think about so often is let me just pop
it H on this box what's your favorite
food milkshake what anyway whenever I
eat junk food I always am liking
coleauxv a mass I'm gonna watch it yeah
ghouls yeah bone wrinkles but I just
want to say yeah I could Mahadi I've had
it stuck in my ages I just need it out
of my head yeah I come a hottie
I think that's as good as place as any
to end episode 27 of GameSpot after dark
thank you so much for tuning in if you
enjoyed this please subscribe to
GameSpot on YouTube leave comments send
us questions at after dark podcast at
gamespot.com Lucy where can people find
you on twitter at least james games
callie
at inky douji co i NK yd o ji k KL
tomorrow at tomorrow and you can find me
at jacob deck and for more GameSpot
stuff
stay tuned GameSpot and we have a lot of
APEC stuff up as well and audio logs on
shovelknight there's a lot of good [ __ ]
so check it out guys welcome Nomo
that's all I got we'll see you next week
[Music]